this is Enceladus Saturn's sixth largest
moon at around 500 kilometers in
diameter Enceladus is encased in a crust
of ice up to 40 kilometers thick loading
atop of vast salty ocean from afar
Enceladus looks like a smooth white
pearl but a closer look at its surface
reveals a rougher reality its North Pole
is riddled with impact craters scars
left over from run-ins with asteroids
and other cosmic debris run until this
is South Pole we see long aquamarine
tiger stripes fractures in the ice since
few tall plumes of water vapor and ice
particles kilometers above the surface
since 2005 Cassini has been gathering
and analyzed material from these plumes
we know they contain water vapour and
traces of nitrogen and methane but the
current mission was to look for
molecular hydrogen here on earth
organisms known as a chemo Litha troves
have the ability to harvest chemical
energy from hydrogen forming a base of
life independent of sunlight in this
latest plume dive Cassini screens past
Enceladus a South Pole at around eight
and a half kilometres a second a mere 50
kilometres above the surface at its
lowest point gas captured during the
flyby revealed that these plumes do
contain hydrogen gas this suggests that
Enceladus is rocky core is interacting
with the warm waters of the subsurface
ocean such an interaction makes
Enceladus a more suitable environment
for life than any other body in the
solar system outside of Earth this was
unfortunately one of Cassini's last
missions NASA will soon send the
satellite on a series of 22 dives
between the planet and its rings a
region of Saturn yet to be explored
these dangerous dyes will reveal new
information about the formation of
Saturn's rings are they as old as the
solar system or a new addition during
its last five orbits Cassini will dip a
toe into Saturn's atmosphere
in September Ksenia set the plunge of
the Saturn sending back what
measurements it can before it vaporizes
bringing to a close a 20-year
exploration of one of our solar system's
largest residents
[Music]